NOW IT'S TIME TO PLAY
GIF-O-MERCIAL. GIF-O-MERCIAL.
(CHEERING, WHOOPING, APPLAUSE)
THE ABSOLUTE MOST DELICIOUS PART
OF ANY INFOMERCIAL IS WHEN
EVERYTHING ALL GOES
BLACK-AND-WHITEY SO A BUSY MOM
CAN GO, "HOW DO I ORGANIZE ALL
THESE NECKTIES WHEN MY ARMS ARE
FULL OF LOOSE POOL NOODLES?
WELL, THANKS TO THE SUBREDDIT
"WHERE DID THE SODA GO," WE CAN
ENJOY THEIR INANE STRUGGLES
FOREVER IN GIF FORM.
SO, COMEDIANS, I'M GONNA SHOW
YOU A GIF OF AN INFOMERCIAL
FAIL AND FOR 250 POINTS, I
WANT YOU TO GIVE ME THE
VOICE-OVER THAT SHOULD GO WITH
IT, ALL RIGHT?
FIRST UP-- THIS GROOMING GUY.
AH, WHOA...
♪ DA, DA, DA-DA... ♪
RON.
>> YOU EVER WANT YOUR HAIR TO
LOOK EXACTLY THE SAME?
>> HARDWICK: YES! POINTS!
(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE, WHOOPING)
I MEAN, THE ONLY THING THAT
CHANGED BETWEEN ONE AND TWO IS
THAT HE JUST WENT LIKE THIS.
(LAUGHTER)
JOHNNY.
>> CAN'T QUITE MASTER THAT
TED CRUZ LOOK?
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
EMMY.
>> IS YOUR SHIRT MADE OF DRAPES
FROM A COMMUNITY COLLEGE?
WHY?
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
VERY WELL PLAYED.
>> HARDWICK: NEXT UP, THIS
SLEEPY SURPRISE.
OH.
RON?
>> REMEMBER TO PAY YOUR
INSURANCE, BITCH.
>> HARDWICK: WOW, AFLAC IS
REALLY GETTING AGGRESSIVE.
JOHNNY PEMBERTON.
>> TIRED OF SOMETHING HAPPENING
THAT'S NEVER HAPPENED TO ANYONE,
EVER?
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, POINTS.
EMMY.
>> QUACK, QUACK, QUACK, QUACK,
QUACK, QUACK, QUACK?
>> HARDWICK: YES.
>> IT'S A COMMERCIAL FOR DUCKS.
>> HARDWICK: IT'S THE DUCK...
YEAH.
LAST ONE, THIS COMMON KITCHEN
ANNOYANCE.
OH...
OH!
AH.
OH, NO.
I'M...
OH, THESE... HOW...
JOHNNY.
>> ARE YOU A SOUP DJ?
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
♪ I GOT TWO TURNTABLES AND A
MINESTRONE. ♪
UH...
>> DJ SLURP.
>> HARDWICK: EMMY.
>> DOES EVERYTHING YOU TOUCH
TURN TO COMPLETE (BEEP),
MARGARET?
>> HARDWICK: THAT'S THE MOST
TARGETED AD IN THE WORLD.
>> THIS ONE'S JUST FOR MARGARET.
>> HARDWICK: IT'S JUST FOR
MARGARET, YEAH.
THAT'S IT-- THE SOLUTION IS
"NO MARGARET".
RON FUNCHES.
>> ARE YOU RUNNING OUT OF PLACES
TO HIDE YOUR BULIMIA?
>> HARDWICK: OH, NO.
OH, NO.
OH...
>> I KNOW THAT WAS GOOD-- IT
MADE THE CAMERA GUY LAUGH.
>> HARDWICK: I KNOW IT DID.
RON, YOU DON'T HAVE TO START
POINTING OUT THE CREW, WHO'S
ENJOYING YOUR JOKES AS WELL.
>> HE WASN'T LAUGHING, HE WAS
THROWING UP, HE'S BULIMIC.
>> GET IT TOGETHER, MAN, YOU'RE
BEAUTIFUL HOW YOU ARE.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS TO RON
FUNCHES.
THAT BRINGS US TO THE END OF
GIF-O-MERCIAL.
IT'S TIME FOR OUR LIVE
CHALLENGE, SNAPS IN THE CRADLE.
SNAPS IN THE CRADLE.
SNAPCHAT GETS A BAD RAP AS
THE APP...
OH, (BEEP), I KNEW...
>> I LIKE IT, I LIKE WHERE IT'S
GOING.
>> HARDWICK: OH, IT'S GONNA BE
GOOD, HERE WE GO.
OH, THIS IS GONNA BE SO WORTH
IT.
SNAPCHAT GETS A BAD RAP AS THE
APP BRATS USE TO FAP, BUT...
>> I WAS RIGHT-- I LOVE IT!
>> HARDWICK: BUT IT IS SO MUCH
MORE...
ALL RIGHT, POUR EXAMPLE, I'VE
BEEN USING IT TO TURN PICTURES
OF MY FIANCE'S CAT INTO SUBTLE,
THOUGHT-PROVOKING WORKS OF ART
LIKE THIS.
AM I DOING SNAPCHAT RIGHT?
OR THIS.
UH, I MADE THIS ONE.
AND I ALSO MADE THIS ONE.
AND THEN I ALSO MADE THIS.
AND THIS.
I HAVE AN ACTUAL PROBLEM.
THIS.
OH, THAT'S MY FAVORITE ONE.
THAT'S MY FAVORITE ONE.
AND THIS ONE, TOO.
I DON'T KNOW WHY...
IT BRINGS ME INEXCUSABLE AMOUNTS
OF JOY TO DO THIS TO THE CAT.
IT... I'M JUST CHRISHARDWICK ON
SNAPCHAT.
PLEASE, JOIN ME AS MY-MY SLOW
DESCENT INTO INSANITY.
BUT, EASILY, MY MOST IMPRESSIVE
PIECE TO DATE HAS TO BE THIS
ONE-- I CAME HOME THE OTHER
NIGHT AND HE WAS ON HIS SIDE.
SO I TURNED HIM INTO A WIDDLE
WEATHERMAN, A LITTLE FUZZY
WIDDLE WEATHERMAN.
RIGHT THERE.
OH.
SO...
YOU CAN SEE HERE...
HE'S TELLING YOU THE WEATHER IN
PLACES LIKE PAWSTIN AND
MEW FALLS AND BIG PURR AND
I HAVE A (BEEP) EMMY.
UH, SO, COMEDIANS...
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO FOLLOW IN MY
AMAZING, INSPIRING FOOTSTEPS AND
USE SNAPCHAT'S DRAWING FEATURE
TO GIVE A CUTE LITTLE PET AN
ADORABLE LITTLE JOB.
WE'LL GET YOUR ANSWERS AFTER THE
BREAK, WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK WITH
MORE @MIDNIGHT.